the number one thing that somebody that  wants to make a change I would say first  off stay in the game you help  the world you help the community by  staying with us  don't check out the next thing I would  say to that individual is make a small  promise to yourself it might be a walk  it might just be waking up before noon  and it's going to seem tiny and and all  you got to do is keep that small promise  to yourself and every positive change in  my life  has built from the ability to keep a  small promise to myself change starts  small and it's a daily habit of doing  the small thing  to start the day and you turn yourself  into a winner by having a small win  every day  and that's how it happens